to begin with i guess i'd just like to
ask how you first became
involved with this project and went in
the process and
what drew you to it okay
i got involved in this project
actually towards the end of when they
were shooting the movie
and uh frankly they
they needed some extra funding
and
one of the people i worked with tyler
baum who's here actually
he'd read the script and said you know
what do you think so i read the script
and looked at the budget and everything
and we thought okay this is a great cast
it's a great script and
the directors had a good
track record so
i said okay
so we flew to new york we looked at the
rough cut of the movie what they had
shot
and
you know we asked them if they were open
to take notes and everything and they
said yes so i got involved
having kristen wake as well as annette
benning and matt dylan
and darren chris this was a hell of cast
frankly for a low budget film and under
the track record the directors all of
that mattered
but i've been around business long
enough to know that you can have
big name stars directors and everything
and
if the movie is not
if the script
is not good or marketable
then it's all waste and i'm sure
everyone here can think of
10 movies where all those things are
true and the movie was
either unmarketable or unwatchable
so all those things definitely
attracting they are positive at the end
of day
i just thought this was a entertaining
fun
film
and that it could be marketed
and as it turned out we were right when
we took the movie and um
um toronto film festival
and we screened the finished product for
the first time we actually had a bidding
war
and uh
the winner was lionsgate
uh
with whom i'm very close and i was on
the board for nine years and they pretty
much lionsgate has distributed just
about every movie i've made
while i was there and afterwards
but this was one movie where i didn't
even wasn't and was not involved in
you know
making a deal they just came in and bid
on it without even knowing that i was
involved which was kind of nice because
you know have your friends
buy your movie and not be a favor that's
great also
i personally just respond to the story i
mean as it turns out i have a lot of
projects with a lot of female you know
uh leads protagonists but
um it's not because i decided i want to
do that it's just because i happen to
like that story respond to that story i
mean obviously you got the movies where
okay it gets packaged by the studios or
by financiers and
everybody gets paid and
this definitely i'm but my personal
experience two movies i'm proud of and
they were kind of came together like
this one was yves bayou
which sam jackson basically
he i mean we had the script we had the
director which is a first-time director
but sam jackson said
look um
we said look we need somebody we can't
fix this movie
uh
it was a difficult
to market if you watch the movies the
movie turned out incredible but
marketing was very difficult so sam
jackson said i'll do it for no money and
in fact he did for fifty thousand
dollars
um
the
frida was the same way i had this script
i've been working on it
um
salma hayek said look oh and she just
made two million dollars in her movie
just before friday i'll do it for fifty
thousand dollars
so okay that became driving force here
uh i think kristen wiig
brought it together as you know
and um
you do that and we've all done that
multiple times when you do that there's
no guarantee you're gonna end up with a
great movie
um but at least
you're not risking a lot of money and
nobody gets hurt if the movie doesn't
work and our mother our expectations are
modest for this movie
um it's already
you know
everybody is getting their money back
is so far is doing decent box offices
not as much as we expected
um and it's going to be released pretty
much in all major territories of the
world
so it's modest success after that
depends on what kind of momentum it
picks up but
my personal experience when you have
something like this we get this kind of
a caliber of
actors and talent together
at the reasonable price at least your
chances of success are
there and after that you have to leave
it to gods of cinema to decide what
happens